The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In the
twelfth lecture,
we're going to talk
about maxima and minima.
Let's finish up what
we did last time.
We really only just started
with maxima and minima.
And then we're going to
talk about related rates.
So, right now I want to
give you some examples
of max-min problems.
And we're going to start
with a fairly basic one.
So what's the thing
about max-min problems?
The main thing is
that we're asking
you to do a little bit more
of the interpretation of word
problems.
So many of the problems are
expressed in terms of words.
And so, in this case, we have
a wire which is length 1.
Cut into two pieces.
And then each piece
encloses a square.
Sorry, encloses a square.
And the problem - so
this is the setup.
And the problem is to find
the largest area enclosed.
So here's the problem.
Now, in all of these
cases, in all these cases,
there's a bunch of words.
And your job is typically
to draw a diagram.
So the first thing you want
to do is to draw a diagram.
In this case, it can
be fairly schematic.
Here's your unit length.
And when you draw
the diagram, you're
going to have to pick variables.
So those are really
the two main tasks.
To set up the problem.
So you're drawing a diagram.
This is like word problems
of old, in grade school
through high school.
Draw a diagram and
name the variables.
So we'll be doing a
lot of that today.
So here's my unit length.
And I'm going to
choose the variable x
to be the length of one
of the pieces of wire.
And that makes the
other piece 1 - x.
And that's pretty much
the whole diagram,
except that there's something
that we did with the wire
after we cut it in half.
Namely, we built two
little boxes out of it.
Like this, these
are our squares.
And their side lengths
are x/4 and (1-x)/4.
So, so far, so good.
And now we have
to think, well, we
want to find the largest area.
So I need a formula for
area in terms of variables
that I've described.
And so that's the last thing.
I'll give the letter A as
the label for the area.
And then the area is
just the square of x/4
plus the square of 1 minus x
- whoops, that strange 2 got
in here - over 4.
So far, so good.
Now, the instinct
that you'll have,
and I'm going to yield
to that instinct,
is we should charge ahead
and just differentiate.
All right?
That's all right.
We'll find the critical points.
So we know that those
are important points.
So we're going to find
the critical points.
In other words, we
take the derivative,
we set the derivative of
A with respect to x = 0.
So if I do that differentiation,
I get the, well,
so the first one,
x^2 / 16, that's 8.
Sorry.
That's x/8, right?
That's the derivative of this.
And if I differentiate this, I
get well, the derivative of 1 -
x^2 is 2(1-x)(a-1).
So it's -(1-x)/8.
So there are two
minus signs in there,
I'll let you ponder that
differentiation, which
I did by the chain rule.
Hang on a sec, OK?
Just wait until we're done.
So here's the derivative.
Is there a problem?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, so
there's a 1/16 here.
This is x^2 / 16.
And so it's 2x over
8, over 16, sorry.
Which has an 8.
That's OK.
All right, so now, This is equal
to 0 if and only if x = 1 - x.
That's 2x = 1, or in
other words x = 1/2.
All right?
So there's our critical point.
So x = 1/2 is the
critical point.
And the critical
value, which is what
you get when you evaluate A at
1/2, is (1/2) / 4, that's 1/8.
So that's (1/8)^2 +
(1/8)^2 which is 1/32.
So, so far, so good.
But we're not done yet.
We're not done.
So why aren't we done?
Because we haven't
checked the end points.
So let's check the end points.
Now, in this problem,
the end points
are really sort of excluded.
The ends are between
0 and 1 here.
That's the possible
lengths of the cut.
And so what we should really
be doing is evaluating
in the limit, so that would be
the right-hand limit as x goes
to 0 of A. And if
you plug in x = 0,
what you get here is 0 +
(1/4)^2, which is 1/16.
And similarly, at the other
end, that's 1-, from the left,
we get (1/4)^2 + 0,
which is also 1/16.
So, what you see is that
the schematic picture
of this function, and
this isn't even so far
off from being the
right picture here,
is that its level here
is 1/16 and then it
dips down and goes up.
Right?
This is 1/2, this is 1, and
this level here is a half that.
This is 1/32.
So we did not
find, when we found
the critical point we did not
find the largest area enclosed.
We found the least
area enclosed.
So if you don't pay attention
to what the function looks like,
not only will you about half
the time get the wrong answer,
you'll get the
absolute worst answer.
You'll get the one which is
the polar opposite from what
you want.
So you have to pay a little bit
of attention to the function
that you've got.
And in this case it's
just very schematic.
It dips down and
goes up, and that's
true of pretty much
most functions.
They're fairly simple.
They maybe only have
one critical point.
They only turn around once.
But then, maybe the critical
point is the maximum
or maybe it's the minimum.
Or maybe it's neither, in fact.
So we'll be discussing
that maybe some other time.
So what we find here is that
we have the least area enclosed
is 1/32.
And this is true when x = 1/2.
So these are equal squares.
And most when there's
only one square.
Which is more or less
the limiting situation,
if one of the pieces disappears.
Now, so that's the
first kind of example.
And I just want to make one
more comment about terminology
before we go on.
And I will introduce it
with the following question.
What is the minimum?
So, what is the minimum?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
The lowest value
of the function.
So the answer to that
question is 1/32.
Now, the problem with
this question and you
will-- so that refers
to the minimum value.
But then there's
this other question
which is where is the minimum.
And the answer to
that is x = 1/2.
So one of them is
the minimum point,
and the other one is
the minimum value.
So they're two separate things.
Now, the problem is
that people are sloppy.
And especially since you
usually find the critical point
first, and the value,
that is plugging in for A,
second, people will
stop short and they'll
give the wrong answer to
the question, for instance.
Now, both questions are
important to answer.
You just need to have
a word to put there.
So this is a little
bit careless.
When we say what is the minimum,
some people will say 1/2.
And that's literally wrong.
They know what they mean.
But it's just wrong.
And when people ask this
question, they're being sloppy.
Anyway.
They should maybe
be a little clearer
and say what's
the minimum value.
Or, where is the value achieved.
It's achieved at, or where is
the minimum value achieved.
"Where is min achieved?", would
be a better way of phrasing
this second question.
So that it has an
unambiguous answer.
And when people ask you
for the minimum point,
they're also-- so why is it that
we call it the minimum point?
We have this word, critical
point, which is what x = 1/2
is, and critical value.
And so I'm making those
same distinctions here.
But there's another
notion of a minimum point,
and this is an
alternative if you like.
The minimum point is
the point (1/2, 1/32).
Right, that's a
point on the graph.
It's the point - well, so
that graph is way up there,
but I'll just put it on there.
That's this point.
And you might say min there.
And you might point to this
point, and you might say max.
And similarly, this
one might be a max.
So in other words,
what this means
is simply that people
are a little sloppy.
And sometimes they
mean one thing
and sometimes they mean another.
And you're just stuck with
this, because there'll
be some authors who
will say one thing
and some people
will mean another
and you just have to live with
this little bit of annoying
ambiguity.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's
a good - very good.
So here we go, find the
largest area enclosed.
So that's sort of a
trick question, isn't it?
So there are various -
that's a good thing to ask.
That's sort of a
trick question, why?
Because according
to the rules, we're
trapped between the
two maxima at something
which is strictly below.
So in other words, one answer
to this question would be,
and this is the answer that I
would probably give, is 1/16.
But that's not really true.
Because that's
only in the limit.
As x goes to 0, or
as x goes to 1-.
And if you like,
the most is when
you've only got one square.
Which breaks the
rules of the problem.
So, essentially, it's
a trick question.
But I would answer it this way.
Because that's the most
interesting part of the answer,
which is that it's 1/16
and it occurs really
when one of the squares
disappears to nothing.
So now, let's do
another example here.
And I just want to
illustrate the second style,
or the second type of question.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is, since the question was,
what was the largest area, why
did we find the least area.
The reason is that when we go
about our procedure of looking
for the least, or the most,
we'll automatically find both.
Because we don't know which
one is which until we compare
values.
And actually, it's much
more to your advantage
to figure out both the
maximum and minimum
whenever you answer
such a question.
Because otherwise you won't
understand the behavior
of the function very well.
So, the question.
We started out with one
question, we answered both.
We answered two questions.
We answered the question of what
the largest and the smallest
value was.
STUDENT: Also, I'm
wondering if you
can check both the minimum
[INAUDIBLE] approaches
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
One can also use-- the
question is, can we
use the second derivative test.
And the answer is, yes we can.
In fact, you can actually
also stare at this
and see that it's
a sum of squares.
So it's always curving up.
It's a parabola with a
positive second coefficient.
So you can differentiate
this twice.
If you do you'll get
1/8 plus another 1/8
and you'll get 1/16.
So the second
derivative is 1/16.
Is 1/4.
And that's an acceptable
way of figuring it out.
I'll mention the second
derivative test again,
in this second example.
So let me talk about
a second example.
So again, this is going
to be another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
when I say minimum or maximum
point which will I mean.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I just
repeated the question.
So the question is, when
I say minimum point,
what will I mean?
OK?
And the answer is that for
the purposes of this class
I will probably
avoid saying that.
But I will say, probably,
where is the minimum achieved.
Just in order to avoid that.
If I actually said it, I often
am referring to the graph,
and I mean this.
And in fact, when you
get your little review
for the second exam,
I'll say exactly
that on the review sheet.
And I'll make this very clear
when we were doing this.
However, I just want to
prepare you for the fact
that in real life, and even me
when I'm talking colloquially,
when I say what's the
minimum point of something,
I might actually be mixing it
up with this other notion here.
So let's do another example.
So this is an example
to get us used
to the notion of constraints.
So we have, so consider
a box without a top.
Or, if you like, we're going
to find the box without a top.
With least surface area
for a fixed volume.
Find the box without
a top with least
surface area for a fixed volume.
The procedure for working
this out is the following.
You make this diagram.
And you set up the variables.
In this case, we're going to
have four names of variables.
We have four letters
that we have to choose.
And we'll choose them in a kind
of a standard way, alright?
So first I have to tell
you one more thing.
Which is something that we
could calculate separately
but I'm just going to
give it to you in advance.
Which is that it turns
out that the best
box has a square bottom.
And that's going to get rid of
one of our variables for us.
So it's got a square bottom, and
so let's draw a picture of it.
So here's our box.
Well, that goes down
like this, almost.
Maybe I should get it
a little farther down.
So here's our box.
Let's correct that just a bit.
So now, what about the
dimensions of this box?
Well, this is going to be x,
and this is very foreshortened,
but it's also x.
The bottom is x by x,
it's the same dimensions.
And then the vertical
dimension is y.
So far, so good.
Now, I promised you
two more letter names.
I want to compute the volume.
The volume is, the base is
x^2, and the height is y.
So there's the volume.
And then the area, the area
is the area of the bottom,
which is x^2, that's the bottom.
And then there are
the four sides.
And the four sides are
rectangles of dimensions x, y.
So it's 4xy.
So these are the sides.
And remember, there's no top.
So that's our setup.
So now, the difference
between this problem
and the last problem
is that there
are two variables
floating around,
namely x and y, which
are not determined.
But there's what's
called a constraint here.
Namely, we've fixed the
relationship between x and y.
And so, that means that we
can solve for y in terms of x.
So y = V/x^2.
And then, we can plug that
into the formula for A.
So here we have A which
is x^2 + 4x v/x^2.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
question is, will you
need to know this intuitively?
No.
That's something that I
would have to give to you.
I mean, it's actually
true that a lot
of things, the correct answer
is something symmetric.
In this last
problem, the minimum
turned out to be exactly
halfway in between because there
were sort of equal demands
from the two sides.
And similarly,
here, what happens
is if you elongate
one side, you get less
- it actually is involved
with a two variable problem.
Namely, if you have a rectangle
and you have a certain amount
of length associated with
it, what's the optimal thing
you can do with that.
But I won't-- in other
words, the optimal rectangle,
the least perimeter rectangle,
turns out to be a square.
That's the little
sub-problem that leads you
to this square bottom.
But so that would have been
a separate max-min problem.
Which I'm skipping, because I
want to do this slightly more
interesting one.
So now, here's
our formula for A,
and now I want to follow the
same procedure as before.
Namely, we look for
the critical point.
Or points.
So let's take a look.
So again, A is (x^2 + 4v) / x.
And A' is 2x - 4v/x^2.
So if we set that equal
to 0, we get 2x = 2v/x^2.
So 2x^3.
How did that happen
to change into 2?
Interesting, guess that's wrong.
OK.
So this is x^3 2v.
And so x = 2^(1/3) v^(1/3).
So this is the critical point.
So we are not done.
Right?
We're not done,
because we don't even
know whether this
is going to give us
the worst box or the best
box, from this point of view.
The one that uses the most
surface area or the least.
So let's check the
ends, right away.
To see what's happening.
So can somebody tell
me what the ends, what
the end values of x are?
Where does x range from?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's the
smallest x can be, yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, the claim was
that the largest x could be
root A, because somehow there's
this x^2 here and you can't get
any further past than that.
But there's a key feature
here of this problem.
Which is that A is variable.
The only thing that's
fixed in the problem
is V. So if V is fixed,
what do you know about x?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: x > 0, yeah.
The lower end
point, that's safe.
Because that has to do
geometrically with the fact
that we don't have any boxes
with negative dimensions.
That would be refused by
the Post Office, definitely.
Over and above the
empty top, which
they wouldn't accept either.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's true that x is
less than square root of V / y.
So that's using
this relationship.
But notice that y = V/x^2.
So 0 to infinity, I
just got a guess there
over here, that's right.
Here's the upper limit.
So this is really
important to realize.
This is most problems.
Most problems, the variable, if
it doesn't have a limitation,
usually just goes
out to infinity.
And infinity is a very
important end for the problem.
It's usually an easy
end to the problem, too.
So there's a possibility that
if we push all the way down
to x = 0, we'll
get a better box.
It would be very strange box.
A little bit like our
vanishing enclosure.
And maybe an
infinitely long box,
also very inconvenient one.
Might be the best box.
We'll have to see.
So let's just take a
look at what happens.
So we're looking at A, at 0+.
And that's x^2 + 4V
/ x with x at 0+.
So what happens to that?
Notice right here, this
is going to infinity.
So this is infinite.
So that turns out
to be a bad box.
Let's take a look
at the other end.
So this is x^2 + 4V /
x, x going to infinity.
And again, this term here means
that this thing is infinite.
So the shape of this
thing, I'll draw
this tiny little schematic
diagram over here.
The shape of this thing
is like this, right?
And so, when we find that
one turnaround point,
which happened to be at this
strange point 2/3-- sorry,
2^(1/3) V^(1/3), that is
going to be the minimum.
So we've just discovered
that it's the minimum.
Which is just what
we were hoping for.
This is going to
be the optimal box.
Now, since you asked
earlier and since it's worth
checking this as
well, let's also
check an alternative
justification.
So an alternative
to checking ends
is the second derivative test.
I do not recommend the
second derivative test.
I try my best, when
I give you problems,
to make it really hard to apply
the second derivative test.
But in this example,
the function
is simple enough so
that it's perfectly OK.
If you take the
derivative here, remember,
this was whatever it
was, 2x - 4V / x^2.
If I take the second
derivative, it's 2 + 8V / x^3.
And that's positive.
So this thing is concave up.
And that's consistent
with its being--
the critical point is a min.
Is a minimum point.
See how I almost said, is a min,
as opposed to minimum point.
So watch out.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're
one step ahead of me.
The question is, is this
the answer to the question
or would we have to give y
and A and so on and so forth.
So, again, this is
something that I
want to emphasize and take
my time with right now.
Because it depends, what
kind of real-life problem
you're answering, what kind
of answer is appropriate.
So, so far we've found
the critical point.
We haven't found
the critical value.
We haven't found the
dimensions of the box.
So we're going to spend a little
bit more time on this, exactly
in order to address
these questions.
So, first of all.
The value of y.
So, so far we have
x = 2^(1/3) V^(1/3).
And certainly if you're
going to build the box,
you also want to know
what the y-value is.
The y-value is going
to be, let's see.
Well, it's V / x^2, so that's
V / (2^(1/3) V^(1/3) )^2,
which comes out to
be 2^(2/3) V^(1/3).
So there's the y-value.
On top of that, we could
figure out the value of A.
So that's also a perfectly
reasonable part of the answer.
Depending on what
one is interested in,
you might care how
much money it's going
to cost you to build this box.
This optimal box.
And so you plug in the value of
A. So A, let's see, is up here.
It's x x^2 + 4V/x.
So that's going to be (2^(1/3)
V^(1/3) )^2 plus 4V / (2^(1/3)
V^(1/3) ).
And if you work that all out,
what you get turns out to be 3
* 2^(1/3) V^(2/3).
So if you like, one way
of answering this question
is these three things.
That would be the minimum point
corresponding to the graph.
That would be the
answer to this question.
But the reason why I'm
carrying it out in such detail
is I want to show you that there
are much more meaningful ways
of answering this question.
So let me explain that.
So let me go through some
more meaningful answers here.
The first more meaningful
answer is the following idea.
Simply, what are known as
dimensionless variables.
So the first thing that you
notice is the scaling law.
That A / V^(2/3) is the
thing that's a dimensionless
quantity.
That happens to be 3 * 2^(1/3).
So that's one thing.
If you want to
expand the volume,
you'll have to expand the area
by the 2/3 power of the volume.
And if you think of the area as
being in, say, square inches,
and the volume of the box
as being in cubic inches,
then you can see that this
is a dimensionless quantity
and you have a
dimensionless number here,
which is a characteristic
independent of what
A and V were.
The other dimensionless
quantity is the ratio of x to y.
Or x to y.
So, again, that's inches
divided by inches.
And it's 2^(1/3) V^(1/3)
divided by 2^(-2/3) V^(1/3),
which happens to be 2.
So this is actually the
best answer to the question.
And it shows you that
the box is a 2:1 box.
If this is 2 and this is
1, that's the good box.
And that is just the
shape, if you like,
and it's the optimal shape.
And certainly that,
aesthetically, that's
the cleanest answer
to the question.
There was a question right here.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Could you repeat
that, I couldn't hear.
STUDENT: I'm
wondering if you'd be
able to get that answer
if you [INAUDIBLE] square.
PROFESSOR: The
question is, could we
have gotten the answer
if we weren't told
that the bottom was square.
The answer is, yes in
18.02 with multivariable.
You would have to have three
letters here, an x, a y,
and a z, if you like.
And then you'd have to work
with all three of them.
So I separated out
into one, there's
a separate one variable problem
that you can do for the base.
And then this is a second
one variable problem
for this other thing.
And it's just two consecutive
one variable problems
that solve the
multivariable problem.
Or, as I say in
multivariable calculus,
you can just do it
all in one step.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did
I divide x by y,
rather than y by x, or in any?
So, again, what I was aiming for
was dimensionless quantities.
So x and y are measured
in the same units.
And also the
proportions of the box
- so that's another word
for this is proportions -
are something that's universal,
independent of the volume
V. It's something you can say
about any box, at any scale.
Whether it be, you
know, something
by Cristo in the Common.
Maybe we'll get in
here to do some fancy--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The proportions
is - with geometric problems
typically, when there's a
scaling to the problem, where
the answer is the same at small
scales and at large scales
- this is capturing that.
So that's why, the ratios
are what's capturing that.
And that's why it's
aesthetically the nicest thing
to ask.
STUDENT: So, what
exactly does the ratio
of the area to the volume
ratio [INAUDIBLE] tell us?
PROFESSOR: Unfortunately,
this number
is a really obscure number.
So the question is
what does this tell us.
The only thing that
I want to emphasize
is what's on the
left-hand side here.
Which is, it's the area to
the 2/3 power over the volume,
so it's a dimensionless quantity
that happens to be this.
If you do this, for example, in
general with planar diagrams,
circumference to area
is a bad ratio to take.
What you want to
take is the square
of circumference to area.
Because the square
of circumference
has the same dimensions,
that is, say,
inches squared to area.
Which is in square inches.
So, again, it's these
dimensionless quantities
that you want to cook up.
And those are the ones that
will have universal properties.
The most famous of
these is the circle
that encloses the most
area for its circumference.
And, again, that's only
true if you take the square
of the circumference.
You do the units correctly.
Anyway.
So we're here,
we've got a shape.
We've got an answer
to this question.
And I now want to
do this problem.
Well, let's put it this way.
I wanted to do this problem
by a different method.
I think I'll take
the time to do it.
So I want to do this problem
by a slightly different method
here.
So, here's Example 2 by
implicit differentiation.
So the same example, but
now I'm going to do it
by implicit differentiation.
Well, I'll tell you the
advantages and disadvantages
to this method here.
So the situation is, you
have to start the same way.
So here is the starting
place of the problem.
And the goal was the minimum
of A with V constant.
So this was the situation
that we were in.
And now, what I want to
do is just differentiate.
The function y is
implicitly a function
of x, so I can differentiate
the first expression.
And that yields
0 = 2xy + x^2 y'.
So this is giving me my implicit
formula for y', So y' = -2xy /
x^2.
Or in other words, -2y/x.
And then I also have the dA/dx.
Now, you may notice I'm not
using primes quite as much.
Because all of the
variables are varying,
and so here I'm emphasizing
that it's a differentiation
with respect to the variable x.
And this becomes 2x + 4y + 4xy'.
So again, this is
using the product rule.
And now I can plug in for what
y' is, which is right above it.
So this is 2x + 4y + 4x (-2y/x).
And that's equal to 0.
And so let's gather
that together.
So what do we have?
We have 2x + 4y, and then,
altogether, this is 8 - 8y,
equals 0.
So that's the same
thing as 2x = 4y.
The - 4y goes to the other side.
And so, x/y = 2.
So this, I claim, so you
have to decide for yourself.
But I claim that this is faster.
It's faster, and also
it gets to the heart
of the matter, which is this
scale-invariant proportions.
Which is basically also nicer.
So it gets to the
nicer answer, also.
So those are the
advantages that this has.
So it's faster, and
it gets to this,
I'm going to call it nicer.
And the disadvantage
is it did not
check whether this critical
point is a max, min,
or neither.
So we didn't quite
finish the problem.
But we got to the
answer very fast.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How
would you check it?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, so it
gives you a candidate.
The answer is-- so the question
is, how would you check it?
The answer is that for
this particular problem,
the only way to do it is
to do something like this.
So in other words, it doesn't
save you that much time.
But with many, many,
examples, you actually
can tell immediately that if the
two ends, the thing is, say, 0,
and inside it's positive.
Things like that.
So in many, many, cases
this is just as good.
So now I'm going to
change subjects here.
But the subject that I'm
going to talk about next
is almost-- is very,
very closely linked.
Namely, I talked about
implicit differentiation.
Now, we're going to
just talk about dealing
with lots of variables.
And rates of change.
So, essentially,
we're going to talk
about the same type of thing.
So, I'm going to tell
you about a subject which
is called related rates.
Which is really
just another excuse
for getting used to setting
up variables and equations.
So, here we go.
Related rates.
And I'm going to illustrate
this with one example today, one
tomorrow.
So here's my example for today.
So, again, this is going
to be a police problem.
But this is going to be a
word problem and-- sorry,
I'm don't want to
scare you, no police.
Well, there are police in the
story but they're not present.
So, but I'm going to draw it
immediately with the diagram
because I'm going to
save us the trouble.
Although, you know, the point
here is to get from the words
to the diagram.
So you have the police, and
they're 30 feet from the road.
And here's the road.
And you're coming along,
here, in your, let's see,
in your car going in
this direction here.
And the police have radar.
Which is bouncing
off of your car.
And what they read off is
that you're 50 feet away.
They also know that
you're approaching
along the line of the radar at
a rate of 80 feet per second.
Now, the question
is, are you speeding.
That's the question.
So when you're speeding, by
the way, 95 feet per second
is about 65 miles per hour.
So that's the threshold here.
So what I want to
do now is show you
how you set up a
problem like this.
This distance is 50.
This is 30, and because it's
the distance to a straight line
you know that this
is a right angle.
So we know that this
is a right triangle.
And this is set out to be
a right triangle, which
is an easy one, a 3,
4, 5 right triangle
just so that we can do
the computations easily.
So now, the question is,
how do we put the letters in
to make this problem
work, to figure out
what the rate of change is.
So now, let me explain
that right now.
And we will actually do
the computation next time.
So the first thing is, you have
to understand what's changing
and what's not.
And we're going to use
t for time, in seconds.
And now, an important
distance here
is the distance to this
foot of this perpendicular.
So I'm going to name that x.
I'm going to give that letter x.
Now, x is varying.
The reason why I need a letter
for it as opposed to this 40
is that it's going to
have a rate of change
with respect to t.
And, in fact, it's
related to-- the question
is whether dx/dt is
faster or slower than 95.
So that's the thing
that's varying.
Now, there's something
else that's varying.
This distance here
is also varying.
So we need a letter for that.
We do not need a
letter for this.
Because it's never changing.
We're assuming the
police are parked.
They're not ready to roar
out and catch you just yet,
and they're certainly
not in motion
when they've got the
radar guns aimed at you.
So you need to know
something about the sociology
and style of police.
So you need to know things
about the real world.
Now, the last bit is,
what about this 80 here.
So this is how fast
you're approaching.
Now, that's measured
along the radar gun.
I claim that that's d/dt
of this quantity here.
So this is D is also changing.
That's why we needed
a letter for it, too.
So, next time, we'll just
put that all together
and compute dx / dt.